johns hopkins newsletter that is mostly
doing covet updates
uh every week and it does sort of um
counts
both cases and deaths across the world
and then
talks about some of what's going on
regionally and in oceania
here you can show now zach um just the
top paragraph australia and new zealand
have both demonstrated this is from this
week
uh the fifth i don't i want to see the
15th but it's not the
yeah i think it was from yesterday the
15th australia and new zealand have both
demonstrated the ability to effectively
contain their respective covet 19
epidemics
considering their success in limiting
transmission both countries are
reportedly delaying their vaccination
campaigns until mid to late february
this extra time will allow health and
regulatory officials to gather more
information on the efficacy and safety
of the various saris cov2 vaccines
and vaccine candidates additionally the
delay will provide both countries an
opportunity
to better prepare their distribution
plans
um i think this makes the governments of
australia and new zealand
uh fascists or at least anti-vaxxers
does it not
uh interesting question and to me it
makes them sound uh
quite reasonable quite reasonable like
they have actually done a good job
on the front end unlike for instance the
united states
of controlling transmission and as a
result
they have a little bit more leeway to
say you know what
let us hold off because these vaccines
are brand new
and no matter how safe you say they are
we simply cannot
know that is something that apparently
is what australia and new zealand have
said and
they're allowed to do that so so should
the rest of us be allowed to have those
conversations
and have those questions we should be
allowed to have those conversations of
course we're in a different
as you point out we're in a different
circumstance because the control has
been uh
poor to say the least at least so
which actually brings us to the second
to last thing
uh which is zach would you put up the
new york times article i sent you on the
covet vaccine death
so i wanted to point something out here
and i want to be very careful that
people don't over
interpret it
[Music]
this is a news report of
a death that looks very much like
it was caused by
uh the pfizer vaccine and i don't say
that
casually in this article an expert who
was not involved in the case says it
basically it's hard to avoid the
impression that this was
a direct causal link between this
doctor's death and the vaccine that he
had gotten 16
days earlier now okay so this is a
doctor who has died
apparently from the vaccine now in and
of itself
i don't think that necessarily means
anything many people are dying from
covid
we should expect there to be a certain
number of
strong reactions people's physiology
varies
quite a bit and so every every medicine
should be expected to have some
extreme adverse effects on hopefully a
tiny tiny tiny minority of people who
are receiving that medication
that you know a number and anecdote
doesn't say anything
about uh frequency or you know risk
risk rise and in fact zach would you put
up the uh covid vaccine
tracker site that i said yeah
nope there it is
um so we have uh you know numbers that
this death should be uh put in the
context of so we have
um almost 38 million doses have been
distributed in 49 countries
um 2.41 million doses per day in the
united states we've got
13 million shots almost a million doses
are
administered per day so these are very
large numbers and one person's death
you know is certainly shocking and
should give us pause but
it's not in comparison to those numbers
it is not uh
reason to panic however you're not
bringing it up for for that reason
right i'm not bringing it up for that
reason but if you'll go back to the
news report and if you could enlarge it
a little bit and scroll down
okay so here it is shortly after
receiving the vaccine dr michael
developed an extremely serious form of a
condition known as a
acute immune thrombocytopenia
uh which prevented his blood from
clotting effectively minor this is a new
disease
to me but my understanding is that it is
effectively
the immune system attacking a component
of the blood clotting
the blood clotting is a very complex
phenomenon that involves a cascade of
things platelets being
uh the beginning of the cascade where
platelets are broken open
spilling out chemicals that trigger this
cascade that results in clotting
so effectively some
catastrophic failure of his clotting
ability
ensued in the aftermath of his getting
the vaccine and ultimately he died of it
but the reason i raise it is because
when we were talking about these new
mrna vaccines and the fisa vaccine is
one of the
newfangled mrna vaccines two or three
episodes ago two or three episodes
ago we were talking about what we don't
know now what we don't know
is anything at all about the long-term
effects of these vaccines because there
hasn't been
a long period of time since anybody has
had them and so
whether or not they turn out to do any
harm of a long-term nature
we have no idea but is the possibility
there
yes it's there not only because these
vaccines haven't been tested
in anyone over a long period of time but
because they are on a new platform
and therefore possibilities that we
could rule out on the basis that we've
never seen x y or z platform do that
before
we can't rule out here because these
things are truly novel or at least have
much higher certainty
that it wouldn't be happening right so
what i do want to point out is that in
talking about what could be downstream
and in my opinion virtually anything
could be downstream
long term we don't know what it means
and the fact is there's enough novel
about these
uh vaccines um that uh
you know and we're talking about a
complex system the human body um
we really don't know what's going on but
one possibility is that a vaccine like
this could interact with the immune
system
and cause an autoimmune disorder right
that would be a big frightening problem
now this is one death but that is an
autoimmune disorder
and so my point is just simply proof of
concept
can these vaccines cause an autoimmune
reaction
up through the level of being fatal
apparently
i mean you know of course pfizer is
saying it's not connected
well pfizer is doing what it has done
from the beginning which is effectively
using careful scientific language to
suggest
safety in other words yes we cannot
establish anything on the basis of
uh one death even if it's conspicuous
um the connection and so um
what i would say uh is
we don't know it is also the case that
this very same disorder can be caused by
covet itself
now the case is i believe all of the
cases that have been witnessed and it's
not a huge number
but all of the cases of this disorder
that have been
seen following people contracting covet
have not been fatal
some of them have been serious but in
any case
we are dealing with a complex system the
immune system
is a is built to deal with anything
novel that it runs into and so this is
an obvious possibility and it's
something that we need to track we need
to be thinking about what the long-term
dangers are here and
the example of oceania deciding to wait
a little while and see what turns up
is wise especially if you've done the
front end part right you've
not allowed this to get politicized and
you've deployed good policy
you can afford to wait yeah good good
for them they had an easier time than a
lot of countries because they're
the opposite of land locked right
because they have entirely water borders
um uh of course the us
is you know does not have entirely water
borders but
uh it isn't easy should have had an
easier time
than say some of the countries in europe
although the sheer size and scope of the
united states makes things more
difficult
yeah well if you'll think back to the
early part of the uh
the epidemic there was talk about
effectively
preventing people from crossing our
borders and it was treated uh
as um cynophobic
um yeah well and at this point
our american passport has never been
worth so little as it is right now yeah
[Music]